hello and thank you for listening to my
talk
and provide data about building a
machine learning pipeline to detect
plastics in the ocean using eolearn
first of all i'd just like to say a huge
thank you for the organizers of pi data
for putting on a great conference um
during these trying times it really is a
privilege to build to the talk here
my name is stur i work at an
organization called sigma which is a
financial sciences organization which
means that we
are a company that employs a lot of data
scientists and engineers to work on
problems in the financial space
part of the sigma is the data clinic
where i work which is a kind of unique
aspect of the organization it's
basically a pro bono wing of the sigma
that's modeled after a legal clinic but
with data science and engineering
and what that means is that we partner
with non-profits ngos
um government agencies and academics and
basically md
who's trying to do good in the world but
it's kind of resource constrained and we
put together teams within two sigma to
work with those partners to help them
solve the problems they have
and better serve their communities we
also conduct in the core data clinic
team um which
i'm a member of and self-driven research
and tooling
contributes to the data for good
movement so we do a whole range of
different things
we are sector agnostic so we've worked
with um environmental partners like the
environmental defense fund
um social justice organizations like the
bureau institute of justice
and education partners like robin hood
so if you have a project that you may be
interested in working with us on please
reach out regardless of
where it lies in the spectrum today
however i'm very happy to be talking
about a project we
ran this past year with the plymouth
marine laboratory
um particularly with lauren and daniel
and a bunch of the other researchers
there um
we work with them to help them evolve a
process they already had for
finding plastic and coastal waters using
satellite data
what are macro plastics well this is
kind of what they were looking for
and macroplastic serves this term for
kind of these larger um
you know pieces of plastic in the ocean
and they can be anything from like
bottles to
you know like plastic waste industrial
plastic waste basically anything which
is kind of large made of plastic and
find its way into the ocean
um these can be caused by you know
weather sweeping
um you know trash out to sea after some
major weather event like flooding or
like a hurricane
it could be you know boats dumping this
over their side but basically it's lots
of plastic
pollution that ends up in our oceans and
that's a huge project problem because it
can be ingested by marine life
which can harm them it can get entangled
with other debris and sink to the bottom
of the ocean which makes it very
hard to clean up or over time it can
degrade into microplastics which get
into our food chain through marine um
animals and also to our drinking water
so there's a lot of
you know negative side effects for
having this kind of plastic in the
oceans
and so you know the first step to
dealing with this problem is to really
sort of detect
and monitor where these plastics are in
the oceans and that's something that's
very impractical to do
from ships you know just sending out
surveys of ships
because they can only cover so much
ground and the ocean is pretty huge
and so the plymouth marine lab were
exploring whether or not this was
possible to do
from space from satellite imagery and
before we dig into that i wanted to take
a step back
and just kind of recognize that you know
this is probably around the first time
in history that this kind of project
would be possible
and that's true for a lot of other
projects and a lot of projects that you
may be interested in working on
um because there's been such an
explosion and satellite
satellites up there that are monitoring
the earth so earth monitoring satellites
so just to give you an idea of how that
growth has changed over the past 10
years and enabled projects like this one
today
um in 2014 there was about 1 200
satellites in orbit 200 of which
um were um you know passed with their
observation
in 2018 that had um got up to 2000
satellites in orbit about 700 of which
were for earth observation
so in four years there's an increase of
about 250 percent mostly driven by very
small cubesats which are these very
cheap to
build and launch and deploy satellites
um that form these constellations that
can image the earth um from from space
fairly regularly
this is only increased in number and so
as a data scientist watching this talk
this is like a really exciting new um
data source that we can use for a lot of
our problems and it's got a really
the satellite data and this kind of you
know this explosion of satellite data
really has some very attractive
qualities to it um so
we've got to the point now where there's
so many satellites up there and some of
the satellites are kind of moving so
fast and imaging so fast that
we really do have almost like a daily
cadence of data coming to us
so these satellites whizz around the
earth they take images and they move
around again take another image and the
cadence can be
between one to two to three days um
meaning we get update up to date data
from
um like satellites fairly frequently
this is two great advantages
one is that if something has just
happened we can find data about it we
can get satellite images
for that region you know after the event
really quickly which is great for
humanitarian aid and humanitarian
purposes
but we can also monitor things over time
so we can actually take snapshots every
day every two days every week
and see how things are changing in the
environment which again is a huge one
for us as data scientists
the other two great advantages are one
that these
satellites not only take images just in
the standard red green blue that we're
used to
thinking about with machine learning but
actually in way more different spectral
ranges than that
most of these satellites can see things
in the infrared far infrared near red i
get a combination of all these things
which can
help us pin down extra properties of
what we're seeing through the satellite
things like what materials are present
in the pixel you know is there
vegetation there is there not vegetation
there is the vegetation healthy et
cetera
and then the final big advantage is that
because these satellites are imaging the
entire world pretty much
um at this point um we have data
globally you know a lot of these sources
have global data
um and this is really important because
for a lot of social impact projects
especially in developing countries we
may not actually have much data coming
from
the government of those countries or the
statistical agencies of those countries
sometimes even things like population
data or population
distribution and density can be uh not
great from places like this and so
satellite data might be the only data we
have that is kind of reliable and
readily available
to give you a couple of ideas of what
people do with satellite data and
machine learning in particular
and i wanted to highlight two projects i
think are really cool one is this
project called blue dot which uses
sentinel satellite data and which is a
type of one of the satellites we're
gonna be talking a lot more about
and machine learning to detect bodies of
water and satellite images
so it uses machine learning to trace out
the extent of the body of water
and it does that every time that that
satellite passes over so if the water
starts to evaporate and the
water body starts to shrink um we can
actually tell that in real time
and this provides near real-time
monitoring to identify problems that
might be
resulting from drought drought or
flooding um
and like those problems to be addressed
very very quickly which is great
a similar project in the social space um
actually came from microsoft over the
past
five or six years i think they've been
working on it where they've taken
satellite images
and used machine learning to identify
building footprints within the satellite
images so you can see here all these
yellow outlines are of buildings from
this one region of satellite image
these serve as a proxy for population
where we find buildings we expect to
find people
and again that can be really useful um
for countries where we don't have great
population density
data sets we don't really know where the
population is because
again like the data collection maybe
isn't as good as we'd expected to be
there i like it to be there
so this is really important for
targeting aids for targeting
humanitarian response after certain
crisis
and also for just like mapping out
population and population density during
like a
covert outbreak that we're seeing you
know around the world these days so
again as a data set and a result that we
could only really get using
these modern machine learning techniques
with satellite data
but as a data scientist coming to work
with this you should be aware of some
challenges
so as a you know data scientist myself
i'm working on this project we
had a number of different hurdles that
are really kind of tricky as somebody
who doesn't have experience with their
observation to overcome the first of
these is just that a lot of this data
comes in specialized data formats
um so things like snap net cdf and a
whole bunch of other ones that are
designed for the earth observation
ecosystem which usually includes gui
based tools rather than data science
workflows
even before dealing with those data
formats you also have to find the data
and which is also very tricky and
there's a lot of it out there
but knowing whether a certain satellite
image is a certain part of the world at
a certain time
can actually be kind of tricky to
understand and sort of discover
um and so we needed ways of doing that
that kind of are very friendly to the
data science workflow
and finally um a lot of this data to be
useful in just the same way is a lot of
data needs to be you know
cleaned and processed to be useful for
machine learning that's true of
satellite data as well
so before we can use it it needs to be
cleaned and that has to be a specialized
process of calibrating the images
correcting for the effect of the
atmosphere and a whole bunch of other
things that really need somebody who
knows what they're doing with satellite
images to
perform and so these can be hurdles with
using this data
and these are hurdles i really detect
you know i went through when working
with this process with pml
but let's get back to their story let's
get back to the story of finding these
plastics in the ocean
so again um we need to answer this
question is it possible to detect and
monitor microplastics from space that
was really kind of what pml was looking
to
to explore um when they first started
their research
um and the first thing we did was
identify satellites that may be suitable
for this um
task and the ones that they um narrowed
in on were the sentinel two satellites
and there's some good reasons for that
firstly they're built and run by the
european space agency which means that
all the images that they generate are
made freely available for analysis by
anybody so you can go online today and
get access to the sentinel to satellite
images
like that it's really easy and this is a
great resource they also have multiple
spectral bands in particular spectral
bands that are important for detecting
plastics which again is is
you know a great plus for this and task
and they have a two to three day cadence
which means that we get to see the same
part of the world
over and over again pretty quickly so as
a monitoring tool they become very very
useful
on the downside the sensible to
satellites were mostly designed
for imaging of land which means a lot of
the software and a lot of the techniques
and a lot of the
the data packaging is really aimed at
monitoring land-based usages
and they do image coastal regions which
makes them appropriate for what we're
trying to do here
um but that's kind of a limitation that
we kind of have to think about and
overcome
and finally the resolution of the
satellites is 10 10 meters per pixel
which is actually pretty decent um but
like as we'll see it's not quite like
small enough to really resolve these
microplastics individually
and so again that could be a concern and
so
let's take a look at that last problem
in a little bit more detail here's a
picture of a scene from the ocean we've
got a nice diver for scale
um and you can see here we've got a
bunch of different macro plastics um
floating on the surface
they're surrounded by seaweed and by
timber and a bunch of other things but
we can clearly see the plastics
and if this was the the quality of our
data then we'd have no problem solving
this probably
solving this problem we just you know
write some computer vision techniques
and we'd pick those out and we'd be good
to go and we could monitor plastic
around the world
the unfortunate thing is that um the
sentinel satellites is a set of a 10
meter by
10 meter pixel size and so one pixel
that we get from an image from the
sentinel satellites
covers roughly the square area you can
see here and
the diver and all the material you saw
there before is actually contained in
this image you can see sort of seamed
there
so like this the entire region we just
saw before just kind of fits in the
bottom part of the image here so
this is quite a large pixel and so what
we see
is we see the reflectance data deflected
light not just from the plastic
but the wood the water and everything
else in this pixel so
what we really need is sub pixel
detection we need to say does this pixel
contain plastic even though we can't see
the individual pieces of plastic
and to do that we need some examples of
what plastic look
looks like to these telescopes so what
these satellites um
so this is where um some previous
research had been done by their mean
marine remote sensing group and with the
department of sciences at the university
of asian
and they were also interested in this
this topic and so what they did was they
made a quite um clever experiment where
they took
three um like rafts basically of plastic
so they created these
um like bundles of plastic wrapped up in
nets and anchored them outside of their
research facility and waited for one of
the sentinel satellites to pass over
when they did that they captured an
image like this and you can see that we
can just about make out those plastic
graphs but i will say that these are
much much larger
than the image we saw before and much
more concentrated in terms of plastic
than what we saw before
if we zoom in you can see kind of the
problem in depth
um here are the three different rafts
and then they put out and you can see
that these are the pixels that cover
them and these images here are high
resolution images taken from a
i think a plane pass and these are the
sentinel images so again as you can see
we can only sort of just about resolve
the rafts in like four pixels and
those pixels contain water they contain
varying water quality so you can see
other features here
they're going to get mixed in with the
data from the plastics and everything
else
so it's a hard task to separate these
out
however this does give us um you know um
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve pixels and which
contain plastics we can use at least to
give us some kind of ground truth
um uh that's not enough for training any
kind of model
um and so what the plymouth marine lab
group did which i think was
like really inspired was they went out
and actually surveyed
social media and surveyed their contacts
and surveyed a whole bunch of people for
instance that they knew about where
plastics had been washed out into the
ocean
so for example in this case um after
severe flooding um this was
uh you know some images that were taken
of this kind of material being swept out
to sea
and they were able to follow up using
sentinel satellite um passes these areas
identify pixels that had a high
probability of being plastic and clean
those to the point whereby they were
relatively confident those pixels
contain plastic to increase the
number of training data points that they
had to work with
they also labeled empty water just plain
water
pixels that they thought had timber they
thought had seaweeds
and sort of you know um white caps from
like waves and things like that as well
so
eventually they created secured a fairly
small very um
uh like um localized and cleaned um
sort of training data set for this
problem um and one of the things
you notice when you look at that
training data set and you look again not
just at the images themselves but their
spectra so this multi-spectral imaging
allows us to get these
multiple data points for the reflected
light we can see here the empty water
looks something like this line
and then all these other debris which
might be floating on top of it things
like um
you know uh seaweeds timber or plastic
um uh sea foam which we call spume or
rock
and they all have um kind of very
distinct um spectral signatures
um over and above the water and so what
lauren and her team
at the pml um did was they
defined this floating debris index this
is an index which is some combination of
these
spectral um lines which is particularly
good at identifying whether there's
something floating on the surface of the
water or not and so they call it this
floating debris index this is all
published in their paper um in the
national scientific reports if you want
to
read more details about that and what
they also showed in that paper was that
if you combine this floating
the b index with the um ndvi vegetation
index which is another index which tells
you whether or not there's vegetation
within a given pixel or not and how much
vegetation there is
and you could begin to separate out
you know particularly in this very clean
very of you know targeted
training data set the different types of
material that we're floating in the
surface so
you know things like seaweed look a
little bit more distinct from timber
they look a little bit more distinct
from plastic
and what they did then was they used
this training data set and which again
admittedly is fairly small and fairly
localized a lot of these samples come
from the same images in the same
locations
um they were able to train a naive bayes
classifier to try and predict where
a particular pixel had plastics or not
and that was great and they published
that basically as a proof of concept
showing that this works and showing this
is potentially a viable way to detect
plastics from space
and that's kind of where we got involved
and we read about their research in the
uc news article and we thought it was
really interesting and
really wanted to work with them on this
problem so we reached out and
over a number of conversations scoped
out two major challenges that they had
the first one was actually just scaling
the analysis up so
historically the team was performing all
these tasks manually you know like
downloading
the images loading them into some
software selecting the pixels they
thought were high
you know high caliber plastic pixels and
everything else exporting that in an
excel spreadsheet
loading that and running the machine
learning um pipeline
and it was very slow it took a lot of
time to sort of you know um make sure
all these data points were clean et
cetera and they couldn't really apply it
to like larger areas it was tricky to
sort of actually scale this up and use
it as a detection algorithm
and the second one uh challenge they
came to us with was the fact that
what they began to see and what we saw
evidence of as well
is that because all of these data points
were taken from roughly the same
locations
some of the information about the
atmosphere and some of the information
about the water
that was also mixed in with these
plastic targets was being kind of
encoded into the machine learning
algorithm so it was kind of over
fit for these particular locations and
wasn't generalizing very well to other
locations
and so really what we wanted to do is um
develop a drive
data-driven atmospheric correction um
that would uh
try and remove that like in homogeneity
between the images and allow the models
to
produce much better results so the
challenge
first challenge scaling up the analysis
this was um pretty scary for us um
coming in as people who haven't used a
lot of earth observation data before
um but we were up to the task and we did
some research and we found
the eol iron package and this was a huge
help this was like a really
really great discovery um because what
it was going to do is it was going to
give us a very
well thought out very well constructed
platform um that would
make accessing the data easier creating
pipelines of cleaning for the data much
easier
and like something that we could
customize for our own
um our own sort of you know flows and so
eolearn if you're looking to do anything
with
like um satellite data and machine
learning i would highly recommend you
take a look at it as a way to structure
your code
and structure your processes in such a
way that it gives you a common standard
for working with stuff
what it basically gives you is three
different types of abstractions
an eo patch is basically the abstraction
for the data itself
so it's a standard that can is a
standard container for data for
certain geographic region and time range
and it can store raster data which is
the
individual pixel values like so you know
how red is this how green is this how
near-infrared is this
um it can store vector data so shapes
and it can also store metadata about
uh of an imaging region as well eo
patches are
operated on by eo tasks which is a
framework for basically transforming an
eo patch so a neotask will take in a
neopatch as an arg as a
an input it will do some work on it and
may add in new layers
and so you know maybe we start off with
red green and blue and then we add in
um the floating to be index and we add
in the ndvi index that we've become new
layers within the theopatch
and then what it does is it like um
outputs a neotask as well so there's a
format that's the same as before
but perhaps with new layers or updated
features on existing layers
and finally you'll learn gives us a
workflow abstraction which means we can
compose these eo tasks into larger
analyses
um and run them as like one full
packaged pipeline
which is really great as well so in
terms of how this helps to scale things
up well what it allows us to do is it
allows us to
feed in our region say for example this
region around scotland
it allows us to um chunk it up into like
little eo patches little like
chunks here and get rid of the ones that
are part of the land and not the ocean
and then just iterate over these in a
parallel process to just process
each little patch here i'll say that we
do have some overlap between these
patches so there's no edge effects which
will become important later when we talk
about the local normalization
and so in each one of those eo patches
we get a number of different pieces of
information this is kind of what your
typical eo patch will look like
we have then the bottom here some
context information so we have a
bounding box which tells us
the region of the planet that this um
yield patch covers
and we have a time stamp which tells us
when the satellite passed over that
chunk of land the meat of the eo patch
is our data
property here which contains all of the
different pieces of information we have
about the pixels within the image
so for example here we have bands from
the sentinel 2 satellite so all the
different colors that it can see and
then there's a whole bunch of other
things that we've added in
through running this eo patch through
different eo tasks but these are all
just numpy arrays and so
any piece of the python ecosystem you
can use to manipulate an empiri
you can use to manipulate part of these
eo patches and then finally we can also
store masks on there and masks are
really useful for
um like including or excluding pixels
from our analysis
so for example in our case we don't
really care about the land and so one
thing we can do is we can add in
a mask that just says all these pixels
that have one and this mask
are land whereas everything else is the
ocean and so go after the ocean pixels
rather than land pixels
and all this gets carried through the
analysis so you always have this data at
your fingertips when you're processing
something
and that brings us to your tasks the
thing we use to actually process the
data
now out of the box you'll learn as a
package gives us a lot of
um ready-made and your tasks just to use
so the first one and probably the most
useful one the one you find yourself
using the most
is this input task where we can
basically retrieve the values for the
sentinel
satellite images um using a service
called sentinel hub
which is run by the same people who make
eo learn there is paid
tiers in this but there's also a free
tier if you want to try things out and
play around with it and it makes
accessing this data way easier than than
trying to do it from the raw files
other common eo tasks are things like
adding common indexes so for example we
talked before about the
ndvi the normalized data the analyze
difference vegetation index
and which is actually a task that we can
just run on our data to add that in as a
layer in our evil patch
and that means that we do have to code
it ourselves we don't have to like worry
that maybe the mistake in calculating
that and it's just there for us to use
and then finally there's also some
pre-trained models for masking out
clouds and for identifying
whether pixels are land whether they're
sort of you know vegetation on land et
cetera
and so there's a lot of like really good
um stuff that comes out of the box that
we don't have to reinvent which is great
so we can focus on what makes
our problem different of course when we
hit those differences we have to
implement our own eo tasks
and eolar makes that very easy as well
so basically all we do is we subclass
the eotas
class and we define an execution method
here
the execution method at runtime gets
past the previous steps eo patch
um and also any parameters that we've
defined in here so we're on board
defending two
parameters band layers and band names in
here that we can pass in um to this u
task when it's run in the workflow
and then what we do is we can extract
from that eo patch
and the data we're interested in in this
case we're grabbing three of the
different bands from the sentinel
satellite data
and then we can perform some calculation
and in this calculation we're actually
implementing the floating debris index
we talked about before so this index the
lauren and the the folks that pml came
up with to identify things floating on
the surface of the ocean
and so this then basically adds that to
the eo patch as a layer which we can use
in further analysis and ultimately in
the machine learning step
and then basically what we do is we
return this new eopatch with an added
feature which we call fdi which is then
made available to
other steps in the process and then
finally we compose these things together
into workflows
our workflow is just a list order list
of tasks um which will be performed in
order um
and each one of those tasks gets run in
order and is passed through arguments
using the execute function here so this
will basically run through each of these
tasks in order
and whenever it gets to named fast like
this it will pass in these parameters as
those input parameters
so for example our input task will take
a bounding box so a little region
of the planet and a time range to grab
data from and it will return any data
that they have
from sentinel satellites for that region
at that time interval
for example this local norm method which
we'll talk about in a second
and takes in methods and a window size
and again that gets passed to
the the eo task that's running that
execution time
and that is really important because it
means we can tweak our analysis
and without having to rewrite an entire
new workflow we can just tweak the
parameters which is fantastic
and then finally the results come out as
an eo patch as well which we can use um
either as part of another an input for
another workflow
or just to analyze with other python
packages and other python tools
and so what we do is we we actually
define two workflows we define a
training workflow and a prediction
workflow
now eolearn gives you the ability to
actually do the training
in the loop of using the satellite data
we actually take a slightly different
approach where what we do is we put it
through all the processing steps that we
need to do so downloading the patches
where we've identified training data
calculating those indices like fdi index
and the ndvi index
generating mass for water and clouds i'm
applying this local normalization step
which i'll get to in a minute
and then export the all the pixels that
contain training data as a data frame
and we just then use scikit-learn to run
the machine learning on that data frame
so that's that's super simple that's
mostly about just getting
data into clean format for our machine
learning um uh
like uh pipeline and then the prediction
workflow actually downloads the patches
for any region that we're interested in
predicting
it does the same thing calculates the
indexes generates masks and applies
local normalization
and which creates the same data format
as our training workflow
and then we apply the model to generate
the labels of the different types of
things we're after
and within the eo uh eo task system
the way we do that is we just define a
new you task called detect plastics or
initialization we load in model file and
here we're just loading in a
scikit-learn job
file but this could be a tensorflow
model or whatever you want word loading
that in once and adding it to the class
and then our execute method basically
just extracts the data from the previous
parts of the pipeline that we
are interested in using and feeds those
into our machine learning model and then
adds the classifications onto the
eolearn
task as an output and that's kind of our
full process for predicting
where plastics might be so we did all
that which was great and that allowed us
to
apply what the promised moon lab had
worked on and their model to these
larger areas
and when we did that you know is often
the case when you scale things up you
start to see
um some problems with the model and this
was um actually reflecting the second
thing they had asked us to work on
which is that these um trading data
points had come from very specific
very similar locations and some of the
the background water and the conditions
of the atmosphere were kind of getting
baked into some of that detection
um like logic and the model and
overfitting basically to those regions
so when we applied it to this area of
scotland this quite large area that we
saw before
what we started to notice was that a lot
of these pixels were being correctly
labeled as water but a lot of them here
were being labeled as spum which is kind
of like
basically this of you know foam on top
of water and the reason for that is if
you look here the water quality
closer into the coast is actually
lighter there's more like particulate
matter in there
which is causing a difference in the
color of the water and the model hadn't
really seen much of that before and so
it kind of overfitting was like
producing
incorrect results for these patches of
water
and so what we really wanted to do was
come up with a data-driven way of
normalizing the data in such a way that
the model could distinguish better what
was water and what was um
basically floating debris we ended up
choosing a way to do this which kind of
ignores traditional atmospheric
correction and just takes a completely
data driven approach
so the approach is to take a target
pixel um this one here in the middle
and say okay um we're going to take a
window around that of a given size
and what we know about that window is it
may contain other bits of plastic or it
might contain other bits of timber and
things like that
but most of those pixels are going to be
water most of those pixels is just going
to be plain old water
and what we want to do is we want to
kind of get a standard template for what
water looks like that can be
that can be given to the machine
learning model that's the same no matter
where we're applying
the the the analysis and so what we can
say is well
we'll make the assertion that we expect
water to have a floating to be index of
zero because there's no
degree there we'll give expected of an
ndvi of zero because there's no
vegetation there
and on average we should expect that to
be the case um over a large window
around our target pixel
and so what we can do is we can
calculate the average of these values
over
our target window here and it may be
slightly off from zero zero
and so all we do is we make a correction
for that and our measurements before we
apply this to the machine learning step
and this helps us kind of smooth out any
background variations in the water and
allows us just to focus on the
difference between the water and the
things floating in it
and so again we just need to create a
neo task to allow us to do that a custom
ui test allows to do that here's called
local normalization
and in this case it's a little bit more
complicated but basically what we're
doing in the
normalized step here which gets run and
execute is we're basically
using the mask that we saw before to get
rid of any line pixels or any cloud
pixels which we don't want to include in
our average
and then we're using some functions from
scipy and the image here
to create this moving average
filter um which will then um create the
average for each pixel
within the window around it excluding um
clouds and land
and then we can subtract that off the um
current pixel within the scene
and what that allows us to do then is
apply that to our ndvi and
fdi and some of the other bands to kind
of normalize out the background water
and then we basically can return that to
the next step in the process which then
becomes part of our machine learning
pipeline
to give you a visual idea of what that
looks like here's an image kind of
before processing here's the ndvi
values from there that we want to
normalize out and you can see that the
water here is a little bit darker it's a
little bit lighter here and we have this
kind of artifact from the processing
of the satellite images and so if we
apply this local normalization we can
flatten that out we can have like zero
fuel it so that there's
a common contrast between the material
and the
um water and you can see here that helps
a lot with the image
it also helps a lot with the ndvi fdi
relationship which is kind of a big part
of what our model is detecting
so you can see here when we don't have
any incorrect when we've uncorrected
data when there's no atmospheric
correction and we're not doing this
the water pixels in blue here and the
plastic pixels are kind of all mixed in
together and it makes it very hard to
define a decision boundary
for these guys and whereas once we apply
this normalizing function we actually
see much more of a separation of the
water and the plastics and that helps us
identify better what pixels may possibly
be plastics
and we do pretty well with this i'm
applying this model so you know using
this local normalization and then an eve
based classifier much like mpml did
we were able to get to about 88
precision um so we're fairly confident
that when we label something like
plastic it is a plastic
our recall isn't great we miss a lot of
things but that's okay this early stage
because really what we want to do is
build up more examples of plastic in the
ocean to like it buffer our um training
data set to make it our models more
robust in the future so
we choose precision over recall for that
and you can see here that it really gets
rid of this um
overfitting problem and this
misclassification problem this same
region of scotland here knows and then a
little bit where we had this lighter
water
that has been misclassified as being
before in the original model now with
this locally normalized version we
actually remove all that from
um the classification and we get um
these pixels classified correctly as
water there's some land in here as well
but we can ignore that
and then we can take that model and
apply it pretty much anywhere now that
it's robust to different water um
qualities in different locations and
different atmospheric collections
and we can apply it somewhere like gana
which is completely different from what
we
had in our input um stuff and we can
detect things like this
this beautiful front like the one we saw
before in the image where we're seeing a
lot of um plastic debris and then also
some like timber and other things so
you know we're able to use this to now
detect new clusters of plastics and
satellite images
so it's been a really great project and
we like we just
you know helped pml operationalize this
turn it into like a data science
pipeline
and added in this like really
interesting local normalization feature
but we couldn't have done it without eo
learn which is a really fantastic
you know package and an ecosystem for
doing this and it provides this really
flexible
set of abstractions that take care of
the retrieval common corrections and
calculations
and that means you can really focus on
the custom parts of your analysis and it
also means that we can now take
everything we've done
and which we've open-sourced so this
entire plastic detection pipeline
we open sourced and people can take
parts of that they can maybe take just
the eo learn uh so the um fdi eo
um uh task um or the uh the tech plastic
ceo task
or the local navigation neo task and
apply that to their own like pipelines
and we think that there might be
interesting use cases for this kind of
um
this kind of approach in other domains
and others of uh use cases
and really kind of the great thing about
you'll learn is it bridges this this gap
between the python ecosystems for earth
observation
and for machine learning and that's
that's huge for us the next steps in
this model
this process are going to be building up
a larger training data set of expertly
confirmed labels and we're going to use
our current model to do that so image
new areas
detect things that are likely to be
plastics ask the experts to
verify that and then use that as new
training data sets for new models
um we also really want to release a
generic moving window you'll learn tasks
which you can look forward to in the
future
um and we're really hoping to get to the
place where we can start live monitoring
sites for
where we know plastic has been a problem
and use that to kind of track
and start to deal with this issue in our
oceans
um that's my talk i hope you found it
interesting i hope you go away and try
you'll learn um it's it's fantastic if
you're a data scientist and you're
you're just getting into this and you
want to like experiment with using
satellite data and to do something
i can highly recommend it their
documentation is great they're they've
got lots of use cases on their website
hopefully this is another use case you
can use to explore that
and this is our github where the data
pipeline is um all open sourced
and if you're interested in working with
us the data clinic on a project that you
have if you just
want you know have a little bit of
something that you need to get done and
you haven't had the time or
the resources to do it please reach out
to us on our email or on twitter or on
our website
thank you so much again for listening to
this talk um i'll be available for q and
a's in the q a session and i hope you
enjoy the rest of your pi data